yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Keanu demora I'm actually ahead
now again some have must have some good
results recently I always been a little
bit behind in our encounters so we've
got this knee is playing the a6 laughs
quite frequently let's see hmm this is
this is nothing special for white as to
be expected he placed the most ambitious
set of let's see
[Music]
probably this is nothing special for
white
you know that looks that looks like
nothing at all actually when I'm a bit
worried that I might get into a
situation where my bishop is a problem
so need to be deliver TM again have to
take nothing much else you know I need
some counterplay some opening the Saab
now that that that really was a bad
opening plane somehow probably have to
play t4 at some point really prevent d5
so Queen here if I get to trade the
bishop I'm fairly okay like is a super
aggressive player but I don't believe in
that stuff really don't know come on
really
that's good no maybe it is maybe it is
but first glance it looks it looks hard
to believe
so what's what's going on here actually
mmm f3 takes rook takes is 94 this is
it's not clear this is bad it is also
not fantastic for sure
all right it's quick this is one thing
it is a really quick mm-hmm it's quickly
happening okay maybe I have to do it I'm
unsure
[Music]
dammit he's going away with this stuff
always hate if this happens really so
maybe it was just okay that it looks
weird um okay so Bishop III rook rook
c2s this thing he just caught me in a
really bad moment there and I couldn't
do much with the C 2 square Knight c3
it's got this b6 business takes takes b6
I have no moves him no good move now can
I'll play this but it's it's terrible
he's gotta be 60 it's gonna be six here
also what a disaster so f 3 and then
Queen a5 didn't work Master I don't
believe in age 45 this is bad chest I
don't believe it
and anyway we'll see we'll see later
this now looks good and of course for
him can just take on d6 with the Queen
and as I have no good reply
no no I cannot do anything I'm warning
just isn't good
[Music]
tweenage was simple and good yeah anyway
it's it's it's lost anyway so I have so
have some checks but some checks is not
not enough I can just take actually
because he's got 96 maybe maybe he can't
play that stuff just key five out of the
blue but white resigned my position
wasn't great anyway that's clear but I
didn't think that you can play can
already switch to two cavemen yeah yeah
this is just reminding me off of the
French defense in some bad way so this
this my engine likes energy for him and
this is actually what I've thought that
this could be an idea but I was just
thinking okay I'm it might not work but
it does work this is the whole thing
yeah this is something that I had that I
kind of thought could be possible it I
really didn't think that this is on
where the engine finds nothing against
said yeah so then he can do it yeah just
a terribly passive version of the French
the bishop is bad and so on I probably
just played the opening like an idiot
you should never be worse with white
after ten moves but it can happen if you
give this up him just bad
maybe I should have avoided d4 I mean I
don't know I wanted to put something in
the center but this is really leading to
this kind of crap position I mean this
is just bad forward yeah you have less
space I was just thinking yes to do it
in a more sophisticated way but you can
play caveman yeah Knight c3 this is a
nice one didn't see it
yeah but now yeah Queen a5 rook c8 is
directly losing probably yeah I am
that's directed using my position is
terribly uncoordinated yeah I cannot
hold it so that was fine in deejay what
he did I just look two cavemen to me
during the game but probably you can I
mean what White's position just sucks
totally agree F this no space the knight
and so on I just tend to be optimistic
yeah during games but if you look at it
now and you don't need the engine
actually if you look at this now this is
just a terrible French
that's what it is
thanks for watching